one more drink one more
drink you know in the morning
for sure we gonna stink one more
round one more round
it's
this is what we do catch up for a few
we'll riff and talk some [ __ ] and then
we'll sleep till two
[Music]
let's [ __ ] dance hell yeah
we're dancing baby dancing in the
moonlight
everybody who is that oh [ __ ]
uh cook no oh god we really were
we're ready if the rep is the worst
[ __ ] music guys in this podcast
i know ah it's it's old it's an oldie
who king harvest oh i would have never
seen that isn't that right
dancing in the moon i just looked it up
that's what it said
oh all right i've never even heard a
kick harvard jeez [ __ ] i thought it was
like
it's not the zombies but it felt like a
zombie's type of band
right now it didn't i'm a [ __ ] idiot
i've already been drinking
i started with a song it was my fault
we're not a music podcast hey we're not
a music pod i
look what i'm doing mark whoa wait
dainty lady over here hey martini it's
not i feel like
sterling and mad men here come on out
true that just that cup with the
the tiny neck on that thing it's tough
it's like you feel like either uh
like a cool chick or a prospector
or some [ __ ] you know like right you
look like the monopoly man over there
but if you got the you got the law of
the olives and the toothpick
killer you think this is a game dude i'm
taking this podcast seriously
these are blue chiefs uh stuffed olives
and
i'm rocking a vodka martini this is like
this is a drinking pod we've
even really done a martini yet so i said
let's [ __ ] dance my friend
yeah do it up i mean martini one of my
favorite drinks of all time i love it
dirty filthy
salty shoot in my face so yeah
that i'm jealous i like i like a martini
because
they get you [ __ ] up real fast yes
it's cool because this is classy drink
but it gets you hammered
it's three ounce vodka one ounce dry
vermouth
that you're just drinking that you're
like that's all you're like that's a
lady drink you're drinking a screwdriver
[ __ ]
good point you gotta you're juicing
fruit juice in there yeah i'm going just
a tad
olive liquid [ __ ] you and remove you
you can tell a professional alcoholic
like one of my friends does this move he
he just drinks he'll pour vodka like all
the way up to the top and then just like
shoot on a little club soda that's an
alcoholics drink
yeah that's kind of a smooth move and
just just to cut it a little bit
i love that because now he can say he's
having a cocktail otherwise he's just
drinking straight
hooch
i'm i'm rocking i'm in kentucky right
now lexington not bragging
and uh great city great town great club
just did a show tonight a lot of love
for the pod by the way a lot of people
came out we might be drunk
pet peeves and uh so
i said give me a local brewery what do
you got and they gave me a bourbon beer
so you got to be drinking bourbon in
kentucky
yeah so this is the best of both worlds
it's a beer made
in the bourbon cask or barrel or
whatever you call it
i love that dude 8 it's good shit's my
third one tonight
they let me take a cup home eight
percent great beer terrible cell phone
battery
one of the finest hey man i love uh
kentucky i've done
i've been to the race track there in
lexi dinkins race
track i've done the i mean you got to
hit a distillery there man they've got
those uh
i think they do makers there
everything's kentucky bourbon i mean
that's that's bourbon you know
it's it's bourbon it's horses it's
toothless i'm loving it here but
it's tough because you want to hit the
distillery you want to get some bourbon
and some beer but then you just get [ __ ]
housed at noon
and then you got two shows you don't
want to do two shows after the maker's
mark tour
you're [ __ ] exactly exactly yeah good
day for my my
summer tour by the way but yeah remember
we tried to do it but we tried to do a
bourbon tour years ago remember
no no i was trying to put that together
you don't remember i was like we should
find a i should find a name
i thought that was cool because years
ago like bert and pete coryelli and all
those guys did the james and the irish
whiskey tour
yes we get paid extra we promote your
booze we drink it
it's a win-win i love it i love it i'm
down
but i think we could probably do that
now i bet
that would be [ __ ] dude a little
cross promo for this pod that would be
fun
that would be great that would be
dangerous danger but you get some
stories out of it you get a couple of
booze bag comics so we who we like and
we'll drink with because
it's a tough it's slim pickings with all
the sobriety out there
that's the thing is like all these
comedians are sober now because they
they drank too much
exactly exactly they they blew their
livers out
like you know five years ago yeah
[ __ ] that's why you gotta hand it to the
stan hopes and the bill
i mean uh the bert kreicher's just
hanging in there with the
it's almost like alcohol is keeping them
alive at this point like if they stop
they die it's kind of like holyfield
you're like they went on way too long
but at the same time like
it's pretty cool yeah yeah yeah it's
impressive
uh i like holyfield they they speak a
little more slowly now
right some brain damage i know
i know and we're gonna be talking about
these guys like in 20 years like oh
sure they're dead now but man those guys
lived
there was something cool about like the
old badass drunk writers
oh yeah very romantic the hemingway yes
i love i love it tells you all the great
writers were drunks
hemingway judy bloom
[Laughter]
uh yeah he was one of the great drunks
too until
he's still he's still one of the great
drugs he's just sober yeah
i feel like every bar i go to they go
what are you doing mama comic oh we had
a talent here 10 years ago he
brought a chicken with him he he you
know beat up a guy at a pool with a pool
cue
and you know whatever every road story
from like the early 2000s
and before on the road for comedy it
just sounds like you were in the movie
road house
you know i know right what happened
i think the cell phone camera changed at
all like we're not going to get into a
fist fight because i work at a bank i'll
get
fired or i'm i'm making out with a fat
chick my wife will see it so the bar was
where you went to really
get get loose and now it's all on tape
it's not just that you can't get into a
fight on the road anymore because
everyone knows mma
that's true as well back in the day you
could like throw a punch at a guy and
get away with it now he's gonna like
catch it
throw it in a reverse arm bar you have a
broken jaw he throws you to the ground
you're like that was
all because i had one too many drinks
you know
so true i remember i danced with a girl
at a bar in college
and i was dead and she goes uh oh and i
got a punch in the back of the head i
just went straight down
and the guy was like don't dance with my
girls like i didn't know it was your
girl i mean talk talk to her
she's the one dancing with me why am i
the bad guy but you can't hit her
not in public so i got a nice wallop
i'll give this to you mark uh this glass
is a little [ __ ] dainty it is a
little like
you know i know what i hate about the
martini glass it's like
it was not made for drunks like this
look at this [ __ ] it wobbles
makes you nervous it's like a waiter
with too much [ __ ] on a tray but it's in
your glass
right it's almost impressive if you
don't spill it like that's how good of
an alcoholic you are
is your you've got this tiny little
glass that's so
spillable and you still don't well this
glass i got it online it's it's
duke's bar famous apparently a famous
bar in london and it's a big ass glass
so i think it only supposed to go up to
like here so i think that's
the point but then it's kind of i kind
of like an overflowing glass there's
some fun to it
oh that's the best yeah it starts
dripping on your fingers like an ice
cream cone but i like it give me a rocks
glass martini
because you get all the love of the
martini without the the anxiety
that's fair yeah drinking man i i you so
how was your show good at
comedy off broadway great show i had the
weird couple in the front row
that was uh just mean mugging me the
whole time and i was like everybody's
laughing but this why are you in the
front
go sit in the back in sulk but
uh eventually i caught the guy filming
me and then i yelled at him
and then he got mad at me and it's one
of those weird things i'm like why am i
the bad guy you're
you're filming this is what yeah i just
did a show in brooklyn and it's like
it's one of those weird brooklyn shows
this happens in brooklyn a lot of fun
where they're like
they give you no energy to the point
that it's like it's awkward where i'm
like yes
so you know i'm not like a screamer you
know what i mean i'm not gonna give you
a ton
so if you're giving me nothing i'm gonna
have to riff on that
and it was it was work it took a while i
did that thing
i do when i can't come up with i kind of
did all my new [ __ ] and then i was like
all right
give me topics let me just and
you kind of get you like kind of get
them back by just showing you
you can riff a little bit yeah and then
that's cool
and that well some of them bomb but at
least i can kind of like
turn it into crowd work and then kind of
because i i
even do crowd work when i'm so sick of
my act or when i have nothing
yeah yeah same same so i'm just setting
up to try to like riff a bit here and
there if i get a good topical bit you
know maybe there's something there but
man brooklyn gives you nothing like
it's they're like a crowd in brooklyn
where it's like
they're they're there to see a magician
but they know all the
what i tricks so true and and they don't
want to get
got because they think they're these
artsy fartsy
smarty pants so they don't want you your
punch line or your turn
to go ah cause it's too vulnerable for
them to let
let loose like that you're right it's
also like i'm there with my friend dina
hashem who went on before me and she's
got great jokes and and
you know we were talking about
afterwards and i said you know i kind of
like
i kind of like when they're bad because
you come sometimes you get crowds that
are a little too good with these new
jokes and you're like yeah
they're not this good yet right and the
road will make you feel real good about
your new [ __ ] and you you need a
you need to be humbled a little bit like
these crowds will
they will put you flat on your ass a
little bit
yeah and i don't mind a little ass
flattening but it just
just keep it real with me like don't
give it don't give me too much and don't
give me too little because
this such thing is too little too so
like i know you guys are too cool for
school but like give me a
a a smirk it feels like a date where
you're not gonna get laid
but you're like i'm gonna i'm gonna keep
fighting
and to at least make this a good date
right now right
i don't want to i don't want you to
[ __ ] you know
it's one of those things where
i know the jokes aren't that good yet
but i know they're not that bad yet
and you're right there is something
about a crowd that gives you nothing
but there is also if every once in a
while man that fight
will make you rip a new line like how
many bits do you have were
true the tag is [ __ ] and then you come
up with a new tag on you like you have a
new ending of the bit
because you had terrific because the
first two punch lines didn't hit
yes it's so true and then at the end
like in the middle of it you're sweating
you're frazzled
but at the end you're like i'm kind of
glad i got that that [ __ ] crowd because
i got a new line out of it
it pulled something out of me that
wouldn't have been pulled out with if
they were good
i had a couple new bits that hit the
last two nights that got zil
i hate when you have that new that new
joke energy
and you're walking around with your
chest out like i got a few new ones and
then they just give you
i know because then you because you're
still vulnerable with that bit it's
still new and fresh so you're like
is it bad is it good now i have no idea
it's funny it's not as bad it's not as
bad as
the worst crowd it's not as good as the
best but like man brooklyn humbles me
man it's
it is you know you ever started now when
you're doing open mics and you would do
a comedy open mic and the comics give
you nothing and then you just
go to a music open mic and you kill yes
yes
because to them you're special right
right exactly they don't see the tricks
and the turns it's like you said with
the magician
but my thing with brooklyn is they think
they're so
uh worldly and cultured but i'm like if
you guys were in charge of
art we'd be [ __ ] because
i'm throwing something at you here and
maybe because it's going this way too
much or going that way too much or it's
too
jokey they just shut off and i'm like
okay but you guys are giving me feedback
and if i just listen to you
i'd have no act yeah not everything can
be david lynch
not everything can be uh twin peaks
[ __ ] exactly
there's gotta be some there's gotta be
some and like that's the weird thing is
that with
jokes we almost like focus group it a
little bit yeah
people don't talk about it well you know
we're taking these on the road
we're literally taking them everywhere
to make sure they work
and then brooklyn is like almost the
snooty uh where they're like
wow us right right they have that energy
dazzle us and i'm like [ __ ] i'm
not an america's got talent here
this is i know this is a show you paid
to come to see
yes we're in the backyard of a vegan
restaurant why are you
judging me you you got blue hair and the
side of your head is shaved and you got
a
snoopy tattoo and i'm the bad guy you
showed up
just cause you look like scary spice
doesn't mean we're on your reality show
here okay
yeah exactly no we get we get [ __ ]
hammered by a man
it's uh it's it's crazy but uh
i'm i've got a lot of road dates coming
up and it's been a minute for me so i'm
excited to really go hard and uh
but i miss it so much like i just think
like new york man
it's not good for your comedy to be in
one place yeah in terms of
in terms of the building it's also not
good for your brain to be in one place
i completely agree you guys are gambling
we're ramblers you gotta have a routine
you gotta have variety i mean
even the walk from my apartment to the
subway i've done it eight million
times i want to kill myself i start
going the other way i go backwards i do
a new train
just because i got to mix it up and uh
ryan hamilton
told me i don't know if i'm supposed to
say this but he opens for seinfeld on
the road
and they get in that jet and seinfeld
buckles the seat belt and he goes ah
vacation which is so great because he's
like
he's got three kids he's got a wife at
home
and that is work and the comedy is the
fun
part that is the crazy part to me is
that so many people hate their jobs and
that we're just
like i love every minute of this i
really even the bad [ __ ]
it it makes me feel good in a way
because
man there's always this great there's
this great quote uh and i might have
said this in the podcast
this is one drawback to a drinking
podcast we might repeat ourselves
you know okay but we all know that who
tells the same story every time too oh
dude it's brutal you ever do someone's
podcast
and they do that like sometimes i'll do
podcasts i'm like i've heard this on
your podcast
not even like you'll be telling a story
not like to me
at a restaurant but this is on a live
show
yeah completely and then you just have
to decide do i go with it or do i cut
the guy off and
embarrass him yeah it's tough drinking
drinking will [ __ ] your head up a little
bit
it's funny all the philosophers like i
was reading this book about like
it's the history of the world through
six glasses is basically the premise of
it like how every
uh period of time has been defined by a
drink whether it be like
a soda tea coffee uh alcohol
like you know beer wine whatever but the
thinkers a lot of times they drink tea
or coffee they do stuff that stimulates
your mind
right words like you know the [ __ ] ups
the people that build [ __ ]
they're the drunks yes we're supposed to
be thinkers
but we have the drunken mentality we're
supposed to be
making observations and telling jokes
but this is the [ __ ] that kills our
brain
well that's that's a great point because
comedy is
is blue collar and uh sophist not
intellectual at the same time you know
you're out on the road you're flying out
you're on the road every weekend you're
schlepping you're in a suitcase you're
in a hotel
you're trying to get drunk after you're
trying to get the hotel breakfast
you know you're doing radio it's a very
blue-collar gig we're travelers we're
rambling men
or women but it's true yeah so it's this
weird sophisticated intellectual thought
thing with shit-faced uh
humble humble lifestyle you know not a
lot of money
so yeah it's a it's a fun combo well
that's an interesting point because
we are literally doing what we do to
move drinks like that's how we get paid
what we do
because we're moving alcohol right and
we're in these like we're in these bars
where they're serving fried food and
we're like we worked all day on this
on this premise let me let me work out
this premise they're literally stuffing
their face with like fried food and
we're like i got the
i got to try out my joke like let me
tell you how i feel about life and
they're just like
just [ __ ] some people are there for
the show and then some people are like i
just want something to do man
i know i'm trying to get get my wife out
of the house and do something and have a
cocktail and you're talking about your
anxiety
blow me i'm a steel mill guy
anxiety although it's getting cooler to
talk about that [ __ ] i feel like
we've talked about this before but you
just the idea of like the old man
like the humphrey bogart type guy right
he just drank away
that was that was manly though and now
it's not now it's almost more manly to
be in therapy and to be like yeah i'm
aware of my [ __ ]
right yeah i think there's some some
merits to both
i like the guy who like you meet these
guys salt of the earth they
they their back hurts their feet hurt
they're hungover and they just rally
they just go back
out oh we're going up tonight all right
all right [ __ ] it let's go
there's something to that guy that's a
man the guy who keeps drinking
to you yes i love that guy
it's funny because i do relate to that
like i do see like a guy who's like
you know you see a guy with like a
family and kids he's like
like playing with this kid i'm like look
at this [ __ ] [ __ ] right here and
then
and then you walk a few blocks down you
see a guy who's like in the gutter with
a
bottle of moonshine you're like this
[ __ ] is a man this is what a man
is but at least therapy it's like you
and this other guy or gal in a room and
you're paying him and you get it all out
you know you're not putting it on other
people like your friends or or
or your girlfriend or your wife or
whatever you're knocking it out with
this guy
or gal and then you go home and be about
your day
i think that's kind of nice too how much
do you think therapy has helped you
oh it's great i mean even if you don't
go every week or whatever you just get
the tools you learn
and then you go i can apply that and
then you gotta figure out because
everybody thinks they're hot [ __ ]
everybody's entitled
you gotta find out what's not hot [ __ ]
about you and work on it
don't you think some people go to
therapy though and just all they do is
be like
this guy did this to me and then like i
think some people go
and just get enabled and get worse
i think some people get better if they
have humility and they work on their
[ __ ]
but i do think there's a type of person
that therapy doesn't help
yeah that's true yeah but i think our
guy tells it like it is and i think
that's what you need
he kind of gives you the business he's
our guy is super smart and uh
funny our guy is like it's really like
seeing our therapist
felt like getting past at a comedy club
you get like your recommendation
you kind of you kind of audition you
text you're like i'm [ __ ] up he's like
all right you can come in
you know and uh i i mean
i think it helps but i also think you
know our guy is a confrontational method
and that that works but it doesn't work
on everyone like i brought
ex-girlfriends there i brought my mom
there
like it doesn't yeah dude i was it also
sucks when you see a therapist
that uh a lot of comedians see and you
leave with your mom i'm like [ __ ] it's
like
giannis papa is going to see me walk out
with my mom this is embarrassing
right right uh you're doing a two-man
act now sam what's going on here it
feels like because it feels like you're
coming off stage
like that went well or i bombed in there
oh dude i i remember i heard
a comedian we know get a laugh in the
session and you're like yo
and part of you it [ __ ] up you're like
i guess i can't like i guess i gotta
like
bring the heat now i can't just [ __ ]
you know totally totally
my [ __ ] yeah you can't be a sad sack in
there you gotta be
you gotta be entertaining and and
there's it's the comic in this i have it
when i'm i'm going down on the
girlfriend you're like am i doing well
the comedy thing goes into every aspect
of life am i doing well
yeah i need a moan i need a i need a
coming i need a reaction
am i doing well yeah you guys having fun
tell your face yeah you treat like a
[ __ ] set yeah tip your waiter or
whatever it is i'm
i'm here next week tell a friend
yeah it's everything we do we need that
validation we need that reaction we need
that
we need to know we're doing well that's
a good point
yeah even in therapy i'm like a little
more enthusiasm please i'm you know
i'm not like trying to get a i'm trying
to get some reaction i'm not trying to
like kill on therapy but i am trying to
get
when you get there is something about
especially like the way like we are such
club comics
yeah but there's something about that
where we're so uncomfortable with
silence like there's like
all guys or storytellers there's people
that will just kind of milk the silence
in the room and embrace it
and i think we're people that want
laughs like bam
bam bam yeah so even in therapy when
[ __ ] gets dark don't you find yourself
trying to break
the tension and make a [ __ ] up joke of
course
and that that joke gets nothing because
he's a professional
and so then you're just going to the
spiral of like
insecurity you're going to crowd work
you're like so anyway uh
yeah what is that a lamp what is that
what do you got yeah
sometimes i'll be on zoom therapy with
him and his wife is also a therapist and
i'll just hear her
in the other room do you ever do that no
i've never done the zoom i can't do it
oh you've never done it
no it's too weird for me do you do phone
or you just you're not doing it
i haven't done it since the pandemic
which maybe is not healthy
yeah no i just i go for like a tune-up i
go like i don't even i don't feel like i
need to go every week but like sometimes
i have a week where i'll be like i think
i need therapy
yeah i get that do you get a discount on
zoom it feels like less of a session
[Laughter]
no no same same deal as in person yeah
it's like a personal trainer if he's
like hey do a put now do a burpee i'm
like if you're not here it's not the
same
this pandemic's taking a toll on
everybody i guess i mean yeah it's
although we get some of these gigs i get
paid more on zoom
that's definitely true yeah yeah but
it's a worse show
oh it's horrible yeah but it is funny
when they're like what's your rate
you're just like let me throw this [ __ ]
out there and see what happens
yeah i kind of feel guilty i just tossed
into the asian i'm like i'm sorry
i feel bad trying to highball someone
but it's like it's funny
the agent will just throw them an absurd
amount of money so
if it's a gig i don't want to do then
either they'll pay the absurd amount of
money or just goes away
right right yeah we we had the same
agent for a while and she was a shark
shark killer agent like got got the
money up
got the good gigs but every time i
showed up at the club they're like hey
good to see you but
jesus christ tell your agent to cool it
will yeah she's
parking down my neck here i'm like oh
sorry sorry
she was a child i liked it yeah you
don't want the you don't want them to
like you you don't want people to like
your agent
right right they'll like us and hate the
agent
you know who they love is the person
that they're paying jack [ __ ] to
yes yes hey that guy that guy tony's a
great guy
that used to be us remember we used to
make [ __ ] on the road
i know oh he did it
leave before that too they were [ __ ]
dog [ __ ] oh
yeah now how did you fire them because
it was mine was not pretty
oh really they didn't fight that hard
for me
well he didn't fight hard he just got
angry yeah i think they were like i
had i haven't had a manager in years but
i remember at the time i had a manager
and he uh
he fired them and they were like did we
do something wrong meanwhile
literally every week i was like hey you
guys are getting me horrible gigs for
horrible money and they're like
well that's what you're worth that was
like to come back
like like what am i you're [ __ ] what
am i adrienne on the sopranos you're
just gonna treat me like [ __ ] and i'm
gonna stick
and the answer is yes i stuck around for
a while because i had no other options
but i mean yeah
no they just they said the root of [ __ ]
to me to the point i was like why am i
taking this i'm out of here
i mean i mean i just remember getting
the first call from a manager or an
agent like we'd like to represent you i
was like
it was like some guy in a hawaiian shirt
in the back of a like a wheatons factory
he's like hey well we want to
we want to wreck you and i was like oh
my god i'll take it
but then you slowly realize that this
guy's an idiot or or he's ripping you
off or whatever dude i remember your
first manager just got you [ __ ] up and
that's all that mattered and you're like
i had a i had a first manager too that
like she wrapped my buddy behrington
dave thurston who was like my
good friend i don't know if you remember
him he used to host my weekly show oh
yeah great guy
greg wrote a great book called had to be
black he's like one of the best guys
he's doing he's he's popping up
everywhere on like he was on bill maher
the other like a few weeks ago he was
not
yeah he was he's on cnn all the time
[ __ ] he's he's great he's just a great
dude too but uh she wrapped him so i was
like oh she's legit but she wasn't like
a comedy agent but she was repping me
and uh i remember the first thing she
was like i was like
get me on a late night show that's what
i wanted late night we were so hungry
for that
and she was like all right just get me
the names of all the bookers and i was
like
i didn't realize that was insane at the
time right
like like any real manager was like oh
yeah i'll email them right now but like
she
she was like find me all the names like
she was gonna cold email them
uh you're doing all the work you can
email them
dude someone's talking to dina about
tonight is like how
every manager should just be a social
media expert now like why are we
paying for people to just why are we
paying like you should just run my tick
tock
that should be your job good point good
you're getting ten percent like they
don't do otherwise they just call you
and they're like
so what are you working on you tell them
you're like sounds like i don't need a
[ __ ] coach
right and then they make you feel bad
like you got any scripts you're like
well nothing new they're like oh nothing
new you're like you want me to write a
feature film in two weeks it's like what
are you correct
what are you thinking you got any show
ideas how's this how many i don't know
if that'll sell
well how many agents have given you [ __ ]
about like your output of material
whether like you don't have any new
stuff with this
how many times because it's happened to
me and i'm like who's writing more than
you mark like who the [ __ ] is writing
more jokes than you
i know i know yeah and they're just
sitting there
by a phone waiting for us to produce
some [ __ ] like you you get some stuff
cooking how about that
i don't agents i get agents serve a
purpose i see a direct result i don't
understand the job
the manager seems like a made-up thing
i remember i remember on entourage the
whole thing was like the manager because
it was because it was his best friend
from childhood
and they were like there was an episode
with like what's the difference between
a manager and an agent
and eric was like we're the ones who
care the managers i'm like
that might be true if you grew up in
queens next to them
if it's a stranger they don't care and
they do nothing
right right you're i think they're a
dying thing i think it's it's fizzling
out like the vcr
and the the sewing wheel or whatever but
i think
the man is organized oh you're a dumb
comic you're an idiot you can't type you
can't
pick up a phone so we'll get the hotel
we'll book the flight
i assume that's all they do
they would send me they would they would
uh
they would send a lot of advances they'd
be like here's your schedule for the
upcoming week and i'd be like cool
turns out the club i'm playing sends the
exact same thing
yours was better formatted right but
exactly
thanks for the itinerary made-up jobs
i mean those are going to go away the
middlemen are going to keep being cut
out because
uh they don't do anything
i i think you're right and i think you
got some of that social media give me
like a
21 year old asian kid and let him do the
tick tock the social media the facebook
uh promotion like what are those
facebook things where they just
shoot out a spread and it goes all these
different geocities or tracking or
whatever it is
that's the future that's the future
yeah i don't want i don't want i it's
almost like they've been trained the
interesting thing about managers is like
it's like they've been
trained in how to do nothing so they're
good at selling you on nothing
right it's like a salesman who's just
like
like so where are you and you're like
well i think you're great
that's what they do they flatter you and
we're so insecure that
that's currency to us we're like mark
normand like
mark this is me being a man you're one
of the best joke writers in new york
city
you've got the goods man you got a great
podcast tuesday with stories
you got we might be drunk that's another
podcast on the come up you've done every
late night show
you should have a sitcom don't you think
you should have a sitcom i'd say i'd
like a sitcom sure well let's work
together and i'll help you get a sitcom
you're right i'll get on it i'll write
the script i'll come up with the idea
i'll pitch it great and i'll take 10
and i'll be an executive producer on it
and
i'll get residuals for that and i'll
check in on you once every two weeks and
i'll screen a lot of your texts and
phone calls
handshake i'm in
but here's the funny thing is like we
don't ask like how are you gonna do that
they just said we're gonna do that
and then they don't do it yeah i i
probably shouldn't say this but my
manager
texted me other day and he goes you want
to sell a sitcom right i was like yeah
he goes all right write me 10 things
that you think are interesting and 10
things you'd like to see on tv
and i was like okay so i wrote it all
out and he was like
yeah i don't know how many this could be
a sitcom and i'm like i just did what
you asked
like if i had a sitcom id i would have
brought it to you by now you think this
was just
you asking me about this exercise is
gonna pull some sitcom
out of me magically what are you nuts
you think
that like genius original sitcoms are
just like
bleeding out of us like these take work
and these take time
it's insane man it's also like
no one wants to make any people only
want to make
marvel or like a story about racism
that's the only shows that get made
anymore they're like
it's either a superhero or something
really [ __ ] up that happened
like we either make you we either want
to make you feel terrible
or we want you to see thor those are
your only options
i know because they want to play it safe
they want to play it save money wise
which is marvel and then they want
to play it safe cancel wise which is
race so like yeah those are your options
and then i was like well i was
you know beat up a lot in my black
neighborhood they're like
they got to be the victim you're like
come on you're the oppressor
here's the interesting thing here's the
idea they act like
like they're like it's despicable like
you guys are the ones making the [ __ ]
like it's crazy how long it took to get
a movie like black panther i'm like
you work for a studio yeah this is how
every pitch meeting goes this is how you
pitch me and goes
i'm a huge fan we're huge fans here i'm
like that's crazy
you own a network and uh you can make a
show
right right and we like your idea sorry
no no no i'm i'm with you i love your
idea mark we like the idea but can we
make the host
not you and uh we need more diversity
i'm looking around
the room going wow there's a lot of uh
white guys in suits and then there's the
one uh
you know blonde lady over there but you
need me to be diverse
it's uh it's a it's a [ __ ] game i
don't know if you saw it today this
woman um
from teen vogue she was like an editor
of team vogue and she stepped down
because she had racist tweets about
asian people
when she was 17. she's 27 now so
the thing is here's the idea where it's
like here's why
she stepped down was the tweets came up
because it was terrible violence against
six asians were killed in this spa
attack
but it's that thing where you're like i
hate hollywood because of how like
you care when it's convenient
you didn't give a [ __ ] about this asian
uh tweets the other day
i also obviously some freelance cattle
dug these up
these people are the most despicable
human beings
like no one's defending the tweets but
like get a [ __ ] life
i know and also you're 17. i can't you
evolve you're like what happened to
progress what happened
i'm not the same person i was i've been
rehabilitated i'm a different person now
but that's out
exactly and she's clearly done a lot of
good stuff the other thing is like
doesn't anna winter run vogue isn't she
supposed to be the most horrible human
being of all time
the devil wears prada is her yes i mean
like she can
she can keep going she can keep she's
grandmothered in
i guess i don't know yes but she's
shutting down this
bad person so she's back to being a hero
that's what we do we
we attack the jokes we attack the tweets
but we don't attack
the actions like shane gillis got in
trouble for his
his uh asian jokes but yet snl had never
hired an asian
so shouldn't they be at fault i mean
isn't that worse than not
i mean making a joke is one thing but
not actually hiring them
what would you rather hear a black joke
or a guy going i don't hire those people
is it that thing law that's the that's
the that's the crime
what's interesting to me is how it's
like a one-size-fits-all condemnation
system and
how i remember cnn did an article and it
was like
people who have been canceled this year
bill cosby
harvey weinstein and shane gillis and
you kind of want to be like
are these equal offenses
we need degrees here people there's this
murder one there's a homicide
there's a genocide you can't just go all
level you can think something is not
good without equating it to rape is that
maybe still okay right right yeah now
he's side by side with these psychos
ah the whole thing's i think we're gonna
look back at this in 10 years ago
those are some crazy times i think shane
would have been good for snl
honestly it would have been great he was
hired by michael che i mean
i mean he would have been great it would
have been a nice mix up now snl feels
like such a bubble
of a certain thing and it's like let's
have some variety i thought it was all
about diversity
shouldn't just be diversity of skin it
should be diversity of of
thoughts and comedy and humor and it's
hard to stay funny in that bubble so
so props to che because i i really do
think that he's like one of the funniest
people man i i
that that show doesn't always do it for
me but like i mean he is like
okay he is like a pure no che is like a
pure standard yeah he's
he's as funny as they come i think oh
yeah got a great comedy by i feel like
we've blown him before on this
uh this this i just think it's like rare
to meet people
you know like i'm happy when when funny
dudes succeed i think he's so [ __ ]
funny
here here yeah he's he's he's kind of
got it
he just yeah he's just built for comedy
his brain works in the right ways
and he's a [ __ ] he would be the perfect
guest on this show actually because he
is like we've talked about guests
che [ __ ] drinks oh man does he booze
it's almost impressive that he can he
was this he put us under the table
hard i think probably yeah he's up there
he's uh
he's such a good him and wolf wolf can
booze too
[ __ ] done it's amazing
you know what it is though it's people
that work that hard that's who happy
hour is for it ain't for the [ __ ]
draw
it ain't for the people who are just
like no just stumble in it's for the
people that are like
it's been a hard day that's what happy
hours for right
right and that's what michelle michelle
is like a runner i mean she's like an
old
type of yeah you hit the gym hard store
now
well the gyms are all i go to the rec
center because i'm uh
are they open no they're still not open
so
sometimes i walk by there and i go i
can't believe i went there two
to three days a week working out because
now i look at like oh man when that
opens i gotta get back in there and it's
just daunting
i'm actually impressed that's the thing
about the pandemic is
i feel like we used to be pumas and and
lemurs and
cougars and now we're a bunch of house
cats
you know we've been like d d uh
depressed or what do you what do you
call it we've been demoted down to like
because you just kind of go
with how the society is going and we
used to believe
man my body's so weak i was like i play
balls still outdoors i like winter
exercise like uh like basketball
outdoors in the winters and [ __ ] because
you're just like
it burns in your lungs i kind of like
that burn because when you're done you
feel so
good for the whole yeah you really do
and you're not cold because you're
you're hustling out there you got the
breath showing the sweat
feels good on your face because it's
chilly yeah i'm with you
rocky the workout scene in the winter
it's like the all-time coolest workout
scene
there's nothing cooler than stallone
climbing the stairs and beating the meat
you're like ah stallone's such a
he's such a his twitter's so funny man i
i kind of love stella dude he's just
like doing motivational speeches and
[ __ ] but he
he's so sincere that you kind of can't
help but love the guy
i did the tonight show and he was the
other guest which was very it was like a
dream
show it was me cedric the entertainer
and still oh my god
i got to meet cedric i took a photo with
him but salon was like
get out of here but he looks amazing i
mean he's got to be what
75 80. he looks incredible
i mean there's a ton of work done but he
pulled it off
he's still jacked still ripped still
tight
amazing dilf i love him i
i he said he's got kind of a tragic wife
the last
yeah he lost his son but uh man
rocky dude it's just the best the story
behind it how he was he wrote it and
then they were like we're gonna shoot it
but you're not a star so you can't be
and he said well i'm not giving it to
you unless i can be in it and direct it
or whatever he did
amazing alone you're not a star
cut to the biggest movie star for like
the next 25 years
it's like god are they [ __ ] dumb
that's the suits man these execs are
such queefs they don't get it and then
they talk to sandler they told the
sandler snl you're not a camera guy
you're not an on-camera guy
well here's the thing my my point is we
get rejected all the time we get kicked
around we're the we're the comics we're
the writer we're the talent
but next time some guy goes hey stallone
you can't be in this
and then the movie makes a zillion
dollars that wins best picture how about
we fire that guy
they don't they don't have any uh
repercussions for these idiots
i want those people in the same room as
to dig up tweets people they all want
them all in the same room
and i want them being like you're not
good at digging up tweets and they're
like oh yeah
i'm gonna dig up tweets on you right now
and then they're gonna cancel them and
they're gonna get sent to an even
further room it's just gonna keep going
but here's the thing man uh no i hate it
man
it's it's great rocky movies are like i
i even like the bad ones dude
dude creed is great crazy i love the one
with tommy gunn what is that five i
watched all those growing up just they
would come on cable and just put them on
he's so [ __ ] lovable man yeah yeah
if you don't love stallone you don't
love america that's how i look at it
yes he's important he's more american
he's everybody
like he's he's kind of adult but he's
lovable he's every man he's got it all
i bet he's a cool dude oh yeah i could
see that
i can see that uh hold on i had a point
there yeah you made a good thing with
the two
oh i think eventually the guy who digs
up the tweets like first of all that guy
should kill himself or that gal i mean
they're they're worthless they're the
scum of the earth
but i think eventually they will become
the bad guy i hope
are they not already well i mean they're
getting hired they're getting work
they're getting clout for
for finding this [ __ ] so i think i think
the tables will turn where that'll be
like oh you're that guy
yuck they're so proud to
find it too it's like finding buried
treasure this tweet it's like
you're not a pirate dude you're a
[ __ ] scumbag you you're proud to ruin
someone instead of being like well this
person wrote a shitty thing
and now she's accomplished a lot and
she's probably become a different person
and grown a little bit
you look at them and being like ah-ha
got it
yes yeah my my biggest fantasy is some
because somebody will find a tweet on me
i'm sure eventually and my biggest
fantasies
is them going oh i got this guy but this
is pretty funny
that's all i want out of life like
ruined my life but i just still if you
go that's pretty good
i would have said this to my editor but
that's pretty good they wrote this
hit piece on me in like 2013. and they
were quoting my bits and dave smith said
my favorite thing to me goes you know
what i read some of the jokes they
quoted yours and i was like i think they
hold up dude
[Laughter]
i was like you know what that's all i
ask for is that the people reading are
like that
the structure still works on that joke i
think yes yeah
i'm not saying i'm perfect but hey [ __ ]
it if you think that's funny i did my
job
what do you got on uh you got any wrecks
or peeves yeah i got
i got both as far as ereco's uh
okay i've been re-watching it's probably
my top five favorite dramas of all time
and i've nev no no no i don't know have
you seen justified
oh i haven't i like the western theme
though i'm down for that
it's western it's noir it's elmore
leonard wrote so
this is a double wreck so i don't know
if i've mentioned this also
one of my favorite books as well elmer
leonard's fire in the hall which is what
justified it's based on it's got a bunch
of great stories in the thumbnail so
many great short stories in this book
there's one i love about um i've been
rereading this too it just makes me
[ __ ] happy it's just
the dialogue so rich i mean if you don't
know elmore leonard you wrote jackie
brown he wrote uh
wow get shorty like all your favorite
show
you know justify's one of the best
written shows of all time but like
so uh there's a short story in here
about this like washed up baseball
player
and he talks big like he's a tough
[ __ ] but then you look into his
past and he's just
like he you know pitching the miners he
was a [ __ ] scrub who made
the majors barely but he talks like i
struck out maddingly i struck out this
guy and then it turns out he struck him
all out in the minors when i got sent
down for injuries
so he's trying to get a job as a greeter
in a casino as like a celebrity
they're like you're a [ __ ] nobody who
are you so
so he but the guy runs a casino is kind
of a tough guy and he goes let me tell
you something if you can strike me out
i'll hire you i'll hire you for the job
because he's a kind of like a
wants to show off that he's a tough guy
and he takes them they
go out and they play you know he's
thrown and the guy knows he's washed up
and he knows he's got nothing so he just
starts gunning for the guy's head like
trying to take his head off
and he keeps throwing him off the plate
and the guy's just like jesus you're
gonna [ __ ] kill me
and then he goes just throw one down the
middle and he cracks them and he [ __ ]
hits it and cracks it and he goes i just
wanted to show you guys still had it he
goes you work on monday
and he hires him and his girlfriend goes
i don't get it he hired you you tried to
take his head off and he goes honey
it's part of the game
it's like writing like that which i just
[ __ ] love like you're just like
that's kind of like he just wanted to
show that he was cool too it's
i love it it's great great it's so uh
i don't know what the word is but it's
so human it's like ego
and all our all our insecurities coming
out and and just you're
you're you're talking about it i felt
like i was there i was sucked in
oh dude it's like i mean what has better
dialogue than all this [ __ ] i just i
mean it's all great dialogue so
he wrote this book tishomingo blues i
think don cheadle bought the rights to
but he couldn't get it made
and it's an awesome it's an awesome book
and
uh man i don't know he's just great so
have you ever seen justified or read
this
big wreck i know it's just easy it's
like
yeah it's a type of book where you're
like you're just gonna feel good the
whole time you're reading it
justified is also just like every line
is gold
it's all right walton goggins and
timothy oliphant are the stars
yeah and they're both just [ __ ]
a-plus
actors man they're fantastic you gotta
hand it to fx they put out some good
[ __ ] they do uh
justin bieber i i don't care for
like they write like fearless on the
posters and we're like get over yourself
you [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah that's a little fearless
you're sad in a [ __ ] house in the
hills
yeah we're fearless
yeah they're not buying our shows that
that's fearless
buy a show from a couple of nobodies
when you're in downtown l.a you lock the
doors you [ __ ] [ __ ] you're not
fearless
yeah good point uh well first of all i
gotta say i
i watched honeyland and [ __ ] loved it
i mean i'm watching the lady i'm crying
my eyes out the whole thing was amazing
it's beautiful yeah beautiful heavy
documentary yeah
yeah great wreck i don't know if you
guys listen but last time uh sam
mentioned honeyman
honeyland unreal killer duck i mean just
a
a slice of life in that woman's world
it's so
crazy how she's living and it's a
metaphor for just
everything in the world how like you can
have something and [ __ ] ruin it
it's just
exactly greed ruins all and you can have
something nice
but you won't have it for long and it's
it's a pretty great movie it's pretty
heavy
pretty heavy amazing that that that is
happening in the world like that's what
five years ago or whatever i mean
unbelievable picture just the fact that
they captured that
uh and it's well shot it's well it's
well laid out
i mean it started off kind of slow like
what is this and then
before i know it i was hugging a pillow
and fighting a belt
dude i love the i love that you're into
it oh man
i'm gonna recommend a movie and i feel
like we should throw out a couple of
comics names that are
like unappreciated with these i i i
always am down for that i love that we
do that on this
yeah all right the movie is sound of
metal
i hear it's great yeah i heard it was
good too i was like let me give it a
shot because movies have been [ __ ] you
know we mentioned the marvel and the
whatnots
so i said let me give it a shot it's so
good it's so it's it's an
amazon movie too so it was kind of like
a sleeper and now it's up for an oscar
which is so cool
and it's this guy who's a drummer for a
metal band and he just goes deaf
and so his whole world is gone like he
can't drum he can't be in this band
that's his whole life
music and he has to deal with it and
it's a struggle
and the acting is so good it feels like
a documentary
damn i gotta watch yeah gary veeder was
raving about it
uh i gotta watch it yeah it's heavy
though it's a
it's a jerker you're gonna tear jerker
it's tough man
it's tough but yeah it's tough
it's tough to get amped up for to to
know to be like
even like i love the lucas brothers
movie so much the jesus and the black
messiah
but like it's tough to get amped up for
something that you know is gonna be
heavy it's tough to be like in the mood
you're like all right time to be sad i
guess
yeah that's true my anxiety is so bad
right now that i just want to watch
either like fun snappy dialogue or silly
[ __ ]
yes yeah give me step brothers or the
jerk
or or billy madison so every now and
then a nice
silly old school something like that
tropic thunder you're like ah i need a
[ __ ] mcnugget
i don't feel like having a hoagie right
now
give me give me some peeves i got i got
a few too okay
i got i got this p was driving me nuts
so i did it i did some shows and this
guy was doing a great guy but
you ever have the guy who he tell he's
telling you about something and you're
like oh yeah i got it man
totally and then he keeps going and
you're like i don't want to keep giving
you
more fuel because you won't stop like
he'd be like oh man the apple pie at
this restaurant i'm like i've had it
it's amazing it's like
it's so good right incredible great
apple pie
one of the best apple pies you've ever
had am i wrong no it's a great apple pie
yeah it's it's like better than your
grandma's apple pie i got it
we've agreed we're done i can't keep
going down this how many times can i
agree
how far are we taking this i mean it's
we've agreed we love the pie do you want
me to suck your dick
this is crazy i know we're done
you're making me hate the pie now
this guy would just keep going because
he was like it was almost like a show
you know what you're where you're
killing so you just keep
tagging he felt like it felt like he was
doing that with me but i'm like yeah but
i
we're just hanging out we're talking oh
drop me nuts
oh that would drive me nuts that's
[ __ ] that's a good one yeah the
the the cocky kill when it's like i'm
just agreeing you're not killing
right right exactly yeah and i'm with
you
so stop stop hounding me i'm already i'm
already there and now it makes me want
to
not be with you it's a it's a greedy
pander kill
oh a gpk yeah because you're getting the
you're getting the nod you're getting
the enthusiasm
but you're taking it too far taking it
too far yeah so
that that was tough and after a while
you were like love the pie and i would
walk away
because i couldn't do it yeah that's a
tough one
yeah yeah but nice guy i just
he was just [ __ ] so much from the
from the agreeance i guess
yeah i got one too i i have a friend one
of my good friends he'll come over
he'll pop i have a lot of seltzer here
you know i always like to have a i have
a
fridge stocked with and i do all kinds
of seltzer i mean you can even see right
here i
even at the desk i have i have original
i have i have a special brand i support
because i met the guy doing crowd work
on a roof
he ran a seltzer company i said you know
what i like your style
i'm gonna [ __ ] buy your [ __ ] and i'm
gonna get packages every month from it
because i like wow the entrepreneur vibe
and i thought his product was damn good
it's called
sound so i was drinking it and i get his
blueberry cinnamon uh seltzer it's
fantastic
i get spin drift i'm stocked with
seltzer i'm
crazy i have a buddy who comes over all
the time
he'll open a seltzer take two sips and
just put it down i'm like oh
you did a pop and drop man come on
you gotta have at least half the can i'm
with you i hate it
i i had this in college i'd have parties
in my my house
and guys would come over oh you got a
beer and they just wanted to hold it
now there's one sip taken out of a
[ __ ] ipa
so i'm sitting there at 10 a.m cleaning
up [ __ ] i'm just chugging because i
don't want to waste it
it's it that that bugs me and uh
because the carbonations it's gone it's
you know you you killed the carbonation
so that's one the other one is i have a
friend who
just drives me nuts oh yeah he'll text
me
let's get it's an on-the-spot hang
always like let's get dinner tonight and
i'm like oh i can't tonight no just
right back
ouch
[Laughter]
that's crazy that guy's a psychopath
he does ouch all the time like i'm i'm
it's like he
just it's his response to everything
ouch yeah
yeah and it cuts deep because you don't
want to hurt anybody but uh you're also
like hey how about you
we schedule something you wacko didn't
have plans yeah
you think i'm just wide open my lady
does that she'll be like
i got meetings all day and i'm like okay
do what you got to do i won't see her
the whole day she's on the phone she's
making sales
and then i'm like oh i'm jumping in the
shower she's like oh geez
you've been on the phone all day how
come when i have a thing you're pissed
and then when you can be on the phone
this is this is the it's it drives me
nuts it's also the type of guy who's
like meet me at my place like
to meet me at a restaurant two blocks
from my place and i'm just like i i i
why don't we just meet like a neutral
location somewhere and you're just like
ouch
why is everything out why is everything
hurting you right right yeah
toughen up but back to the seltzer thing
with the one sip out of it the pop and
drop
you wouldn't do that with food if you
were like hey you got any food
you wouldn't take a taco take one bite
and put it down it's something with
with liquids that's true although he it
depends on the food he will do it like i
have
trail mix out all the time and he'll
he'll he'll take scoops and
that to me i'm like that's perfect
that's there for scoops take
take whatever food you want here i i'm
totally like i
you know i i'm i have more groceries in
my apartment than i've ever had just
because of the pandemic just because
right
i just i'm here more i'm not used to
being home
this often so i got chips i got you know
trail mix i got string cheese i got all
kinds of good stuff here
oh see how do you i i would just eat all
of it in one sitting
i eat it all i'm disgusting yeah that's
why i don't do that the chopping
what so you just eat out every meal i i
do
oatmeal for breakfast i keep a bunch of
bananas a couple of oranges
and i buy a rotisserie chicken and then
i bought a bunch of trail mix as well
and i just live off of that
for the for the week but i i for dinner
i eat out pretty much every night yeah
you have no you have no willpower with
when you have the snacks
me neither but i just that's the other
thing i'll get drunk and i'm just like
stuffing my face with snacks and treats
and i just
but i also i'm like i mean what like
we could have worse vices i think i mean
i also think like you know whatever
i made i made a douchey rule with the
pant no food after 11. that was like my
pandemic rule
because i was eating like snacking at
midnight you know
watching tv with in my underwear so i
had to make that rule
yeah but you're [ __ ] you're fine man
i mean i think you gotta you gotta treat
yourself because
anxiety like you got to have something
you can't have nothing
you got to have something scoop a trail
mix is
not the worst thing in the world for you
no no no no
that's right any other do you have any
other pet peeves
uh no that was my big one um
oh how about this this is a pet peeve
this is something i think this might be
a lady thing
so we'll be watching a movie and then
she'll be talking to me during the movie
and i'm like okay so should i listen to
the movie or should i listen to you like
we got to pick which one we're doing now
not trying to be a dick
but then she'll talk to me throughout
the movie and if i pause it she gets
annoyed like oh sorry
oh and i'm like well i'd like to hear
the movie but i also want to hear you
didn't mean to that's crazy so i don't
pause it
and then she'll talk to me and then go
what do you say
like what do you mean what he's saying
you talk to me the whole time how do i
know what he said
this is on a movie you've never seen
before she's doing this
yes unacceptable unacceptable she'll go
at me and then she's like what do you
say i'm like i don't know i was
listening to you
isn't that a compliment i don't know
what he said either because you were
talking
see this is why you re-watch shows as a
couple
so you can do the talking because some
people like all we watch a simpsons or
south park or like succession's great
for this because you're like we'll just
talk because we've seen this before
but when you're doing a first time you
think i want to just talk i missed an
important piece of dialogue
that was plot centric i know exactly it
might be she's a younger gal
she's 11 years old so maybe it's a
generational thing i don't know
children are the worst yeah yeah yeah
because is this too dark a joke let me
run this bit by you tell me this is too
dark
like when you regret when you hook up
with someone immediately i wonder if
pedophiles do that
do you think pedophiles like after they
[ __ ] someone they're just like oh my god
are you still
here jesus christ
that's interesting i mean that's that's
a funny idea
and i'm i'm actually intrigued that's a
great bit
i will never it might i might be the
wrong guy to ask but i think that's
right you are i appreciate it i think
it's gonna bomb
what uh give me uh no more pet peeves
no no those are my two big ones
and then the talking during the movie
that asking what they said
i hate a movie talk i mean i'm okay with
it if it's if
here's the thing once you've paused the
movie
you've done the right thing like she
can't be offended by the pause you're
doing
you're saying i don't want to miss the
movie but i'd like to hear what you're
trying to say there's a most polite
thing you can do
exactly i mean i will say she does have
a skill
of like she'll be scrolling on her phone
while the movie is on
and then i'll be like oh wait what who's
that guy and she's like oh that's the
guy from the
the the work work guy i'm like oh how do
you know more than me i've been watching
it while you're tick-tocking
yeah you know what it is young people
man i feel like they also are just like
they're just looking up [ __ ] about the
movie too sometimes aren't they like
that's a young person thing
that's true too i do that sometimes too
if i'm just like sometimes i'll be
watching a movie i'm like i wonder if
this actor is still alive or something
you
know
definitely definitely i was watching the
other day that i i hadn't seen so i was
a little kid that's just such a classic
is uh vertigo
hitchcock oh yeah classic dude it's so
good
i mean without hitchcock you wouldn't
have all the tropes and all the
movie moves that he did i mean he
invented a lot of [ __ ]
hitchcock [ __ ] rules so good
so good big fan uh you got a bit
yeah let me see what i got this this
might be stupid tell me if there's too
stupid i think it's kind of fun
hit last night bomb tonight so people
when they have a stroke they smell they
smell burnt toast before they have a
stroke
yes so it's like that's that's annoying
because that sucks but it doesn't suck
nearly as bad as a stroke
you know i mean it's like kind of it's
annoying but it's not it's like that
doesn't help with any other horrible
thing like that it's never like who
farted then you're like [ __ ]
age oh man
that's great isn't it hey hey brooklyn
if you're listening you're on my show
tonight you should have [ __ ] laughed
i got
so many jokes like that that got no
that's great i mean you got a fart
aids i mean that's a yeah so silly and
dumb it got
zero yeah i almost dropped it uh what do
you got
wow now don't drop that that's something
i like that uh
i got some real weak ideas so my wallet
got stolen
just recently yeah like two days ago it
was a nightmare
um so i'm trying to get some some
material out of it
uh first of all i thought
wouldn't it be nice if the guy who stole
the wallet the punishment if we catch
the guy
it should be him having to go to the dmv
and getting my license back
like you got to do that [ __ ] you know
because that's the worst part it's not
the money it's not that it's it's the
actual
handling of all the chores now that i
have to do
yeah dude i do this [ __ ] i do like the
uh like i have it on the back of my uh
phone yeah that's not bad but i'm i
can't
i can't keep my eyes off my phone anyway
i might as well put it all in one place
you know that's
true but if you lose the phone you're
really [ __ ]
true but if i lose the phone i'm [ __ ]
anyway yeah i guess so
so that's so that's the other angle i
like the dmv angle
about like he's got to do the bad [ __ ]
so
did he steal it do you even get mugged
you dropped it somewhere
i had my wallet my friend's car window
broken
right off second avenue broke the window
took i had my jeans in my in the car and
he just took the jeans and had the
wallet in it
oh my god man yeah old school man new
york new york's getting wild this is the
east village
11th street broke the window of his
[ __ ] car
that sucks crazy like just seeing the
glass shatter you're like oh that's
crazy then you see the jeans gone and
you're like well there goes the wallet
but
uh so then i thought another funny thing
could be
you take the wallet it'd be cool when
you stole my wallet you had my problems
too
like you got you got my financial burden
you got my college debt you got my uh
whatever it is you know some you got my
blockbuster fees
i don't know if there's anything there i
like the i like the
dmv thing a lot i like that i think the
thing about like the the dmv
is uh you're like and what are you here
for you just he just holds up a picture
of you
and they like take a picture of it a new
driver's license
photo right um did they catch him
no no we called the cops like yeah you
know what some guy's got your wallet
and you know and a crack house who knows
what the [ __ ] you know
the only problem with the with the um
the identity i've heard the identity
it's different bit but it's like kind of
close was like they took my identity but
they were like
we have my [ __ ] identity though
really you know so that's the only
problem
i think the dmv angle is is the angle to
pursue
okay okay about like uh
they broke a [ __ ] window there might
be something there but
they broke like in a weird way you're
like
it's not like yeah it's a weird thing
where you're like me you [ __ ] whose car
was it was a comic
no it was just i was shooting a thing
with this guy and he was a nice guy i
met him that day but he had this nice
mercedes
and so i was wearing a costume for the
shoot and so
i guess they saw the mercedes and i put
my jeans in the car
and he got it dude you almost you almost
should be mad at him for
not parking lot in a mercedes in the
current east village
that's almost like blood on his hands
for that [ __ ] all right
yeah uh so then the other angle is
you lose your wallet it sucks but losing
your phone is worse because there's a
wallet on the phone
you know you can use your phone to pay
for things and
use your facial recognition but you
can't use your wallet to make a phone
call
and the phone is almost one
yeah you can't call an uber with your
wallet can't do it
you're trapped right yeah without the
without the wallet you can survive
without the phone
even with the phone you could be like
you don't have any id
i do have id google mark norman right
right
exactly yeah cat they say cash is king
but the phone is king
the phone is king man the wallet doesn't
like i mean you can kind of just survive
without a wallet you got seamless you
got uber
you got um apple pay
you kind of don't need like at some
point you're like you're like maybe this
dude pushed me into the future
that's interesting yeah yeah i mean the
the wallet doesn't
like every like have cash on you and
you're like what is this [ __ ] 1994
you know what i mean like yeah the cash
is almost for like
only for me to like tip people with at
this point i know
i know it doesn't feel like cash is king
anymore it's so true
mean it's like look at you you don't
have a wallet so what does that tell you
your wallet
is all your shit's connected to your
phone i do i do this
just like have some cash i mean i'll do
like a little money clip like that just
in my pocket
but i yeah i have all my thing on um
things on my phone cause i'm just like
why would i
i mean did you have your phone on you
when you got robbed
uh no i had the phone on me thank god
that's what i'm saying
if you had your if your phone was your
wallet
exactly i'd be screwed so it's an idea
i'm trying to get something out of
something out of it there's something
there
yeah about breaking into the car too
all right well what about let me try
this on you and then i'll let you go
because uh this
this that that's like a topical this
just happened to me thing but this is an
idea i had
and tell me if it's been done
it's weird that when like when i was a
kid i wanted a pet
i wanted a dog and my mom was like uh
that's a big responsibility
you got to feed it you got to clean up
after it i don't know if it's a good
idea and she like talked me out of
getting a dog
but if i told my mom hey i'm ready to
have kids
she'd be like go for it i'm like isn't
that weird
the kids are way bigger responsibility
and the dog
she'll end up taking care of anyway and
the kids probably too
it's very relatable yeah it's done
i haven't heard it like that no it's
interesting it's like
my mom would do the exact same thing you
know why
because dog still feels like you're
delaying adulthood in some way to them
but kid is like we're doing it that i
think that's how they see it and that
maybe that's
there's a way to spin that where you're
like a kid
i always wanted you know what it is
because you know this is what
might be the whole time you're a
teenager you're like mom can i have a
dog she's like no
mom can i have a dog but if you're
pestering her
mom can i have a kid she'd be like what
right
maybe there's some angle to play like
that like having a dog
is like a kid thing almost
well how about this when you ask for a
dog your mom has to get the dog but when
you're like i'm having a kid she's like
that's on you and your girlfriend like
you guys cause
you're not [ __ ] your mom so it's not
even she's not even involved with the
dog she's involved
you can get a dog walker when you go out
of town when you get a when you get a
kid you you gotta ask for your mom so
maybe i don't know
yeah because i think it's almost like
hey it's sexual with you
uh yeah you figure it out go go nuts but
with the dog it's like oh i'm involved
in this
it's weird because the dog thing
i guess it's that it just feels more
serious we're having a fair we're
starting a family like no one takes it
seriously like we're getting a dog we're
starting to yeah
yeah you're having a baby you're like
we're starting a family it's a big deal
and she probably looks at it like
because you told her you got it because
you got a cat did she say anything to
that
no she didn't care she didn't care about
the cat but no one gets i was a kid
i wanted a dog and she was like i don't
know that's a big responsibility i'm
like
but if i had a kid you'd be all for it
like that's a way bigger a dog you leave
for the weekend you leave a pile of food
and you're good
although if you have a kid when you're a
teenager your mom's like [ __ ] should
have gotten
that dog oh yeah that's not bad
yeah i'm taking care of either one
anyway there's something there
yeah i like this angle the mom wants
the uh
wants to be a grandson but she doesn't
want to be a pet pet owner
yeah well that's she's got a story to
tell with the baby there's no story my
son got a [ __ ] dog who gives a [ __ ]
hey right right here's a picture of your
son's dog
i care why this is my grandson there's
no name for the son's dog
yes yes i'm a grandma that's the name
you got a new title it's almost like
saying i'm gonna get a bike
versus i'm gonna get a car you know your
mom's like uh who cares you're getting a
bike all right whatever
yeah there's a city bike who gives a
[ __ ] yeah but you get a car like oh you
got a car
it's you're right it's you're jumping
all in it's a bigger deal
you're gonna be a father compared to
like are you gonna have a [ __ ] dog
around
you give the dog to a friend because you
couldn't handle it you're not getting
that much judgment you give that baby up
uh-huh i mean that's the difference in
commitment right there you give the baby
to your friend your mom's like
you just gave away the baby you're like
yeah we wanted to go on vacation
yeah yes cut to me outside of a walmart
with a baby in a cardboard box
all right all right that helps something
there i'll try it this weekend
i please do comedy on broadway the great
i'll be there in august i love kentucky
it's a great state i love it too i love
this hotel i love it's right by the club
i love that [ __ ] i'm looking forward
yeah i love uh
i love the road i can't wait to get back
to it man the road just get in that
green room you order the shitty salmon
you got a cocktail
i mean it's the little things baby just
feels so good
i can't wait well make sure to email us
at uh
we might be drunk pot at gmail.com with
your pet peeves
your wrecks your jokes everything you
got we'll we'll read them on the patreon
so
subscribe to patreon.com we might be
drunk pod or it might be
we might yes we might be drunk pod
that's right yeah and uh
yeah and just keep i mean i'm having a
great time with this man keep listening
to this
keep uh keep telling your friends yes
and uh quoted we've got your characters
on instagram we got where we're on
instagram with our own page
follow that and uh yeah tell a friend
spread the love spread the cheeks and
and tell us about some some cocktails
you like because
you've already learned about a few we
might be drunk on instagram and follow
mark and myself obviously and see us on
the road i'm actually doing my last
virtual show on monday so
you get tickets to that it's on zoom so
if you live in melbourne or
some [ __ ] where you won't see me for a
while buy a ticket it's fun i'm working
on new [ __ ]
uh samurail.com shows
and uh yeah i got connecticut coming up
atlantic city
all on my website uh arlington and and
much more coming soon but uh mark what
do you got man i'm all over the road as
well
marknormancomedy.com check it out all
kinds of fun dates
uh columbus funny bone coming up uh
what else uh boy uh
wise guys in utah tacoma comedy club
mcgoobies
you name it hartford funny bone that'll
be tough spokane comedy
funny funny bone in virginia beach never
been there
you ever done that one i haven't done
virginia beach funny by now
portland helium all kinds of fun stuff
funny about syracuse hey
please come on to that i need your
[ __ ] warriors
i walked a lot of people in that room
yeah yeah that's a tough one it's in a
mall it's next to a toby keith that's in
syracuse
how many bad things can i say
but yeah good stuff all right well
thanks man
a good good drink and enjoy that martini
i killed it i killed a couple of them i
i had them i had the shaker right here
i'm [ __ ]
oh i love this [ __ ] i got a little
shaker going
you bring a girl over and do that she's
like all right i'm in good hands
it's pretty cool pretty clean nothing
better well dude it's great to see it
and
uh i mean it's like tough i can't wait
to like i can't wait till we do this in
the studio that's or like
we should use in a bar yes we got to do
it in a bar
fat black whatever it is we'll talk to
liz
yeah that's a game changer we'll go from
here to here
oh my god you think that that'll give us
a bump oh yeah
big bump and just i think we'll be
better face to face you know
there's pheromones and energy and
connections
i miss your smell dog yeah for sure
all right all right sweet i'm loving
this so i hope you guys listen to liking
it too
yes and keep sending those jokes they're
fun
all right take it easy